[Música]
hoy en directo a nos vamos hasta
Washington con nuestro corresponsal
Cristóbal Vázquez ahí este martes tendrá
lugar el discurso de Joe biden sobre el
estado de la unión en él se espera que
vayan hablen más sobre lo conseguido
hasta ahora por su gobierno que sobre
nuevas propuestas también que tienda la
mano a los republicanos para negociar el
techo de la deuda según una encuesta
publicada este lunes la mayoría de
estadounidenses ven con preocupación el
déficit presupuestario Cristóbal se
tienen más detalles sobre los puntos en
los que se centrará biden
sí se conocen detalles y usted lo
mencionaba bien este este discurso de la
unión se va a Resaltar lo que ha hecho
biden en los primeros dos años de
gobierno y va a proponer los a las
políticas que espera hacer y espera
lograr en los próximos dos años se
centrarán el tema de la inflación que
fue una de las promesas claves que hizo
en el último discurso de inflación de
precisamente bajarle los precios a los
estadounidenses ahí
se pegará de alguna forma de los abuelos
datos que ha arrojado la reserva federal
y los pronósticos de los economistas de
que el próximo año empezando el próximo
año pues la inflación estará pues es
justo cerca al 3% en Estados Unidos una
cifra muy inferior a lo que vivió
Estados Unidos en el 2022 en cuanto a
inflación también hablará de cómo ha
logrado bajar los precios de los
medicamentos y marginalmente también
como ha logrado bajar los precios de la
energía en logros que seguramente
resaltará y hará
énfasis en el hecho de que las empresas
grandes empresas en Estados Unidos van a
tener que empezar pronto a pagar su
justa tajada en cuanto a impuestos como
lo ha repetido varias veces el
presidente sin embargo recordemos que en
este intento para que las
multinacionales y las grandes empresas
acá en Estados Unidos pagarán más
impuestos pues no pudo lograrlo porque
no fue aprobado ese intento de subir los
impuestos a las grandes empresas
precisamente para financiar este déficit
y esta deuda que está en negociación
Pues precisamente del techo de la deuda
quiero hablar porque hoy ha hablado
también el líder republicano en el
senado Kevin mccarthy que ha dicho y en
qué puntos se encuentran en la cámara de
representantes Perdón que ha dicho y en
qué punto se encuentran demócratas y
republicanos respecto a este tema
sí lo que dijo Kevin mccarthy fue que él
no ve nada de malo en usar la el debate
y el aumento del límite de la deuda
estadounidense la deuda pública
estadounidense como una herramienta de
negociación precisamente para que la
casa blanca y los demócratas hagan
recortes donde quieren que los
republicanos hagan recortes sin embargo
pues hay que aclarar que el debate está
centrado en que durante la pandemia y
precisamente de cara la inflación el
gobierno de Estados Unidos tuvo que
hacer grandes gastos para ayudarle a los
estadounidenses a poder pasar este
impase que generó precisamente la
pandemia esto generó mucho gasto público
y por eso este gobierno de Joe biden
quiere aumentar este límite de la deuda
sin embargo pues
está diciendo que pues no hubo nada de
malo en usar este debate y está
necesidad de aumentar el límite de la
deuda en Estados Unidos para no entrar
en default como una herramienta para
Pues a tratar de que los demócratas
hagan recortes en las áreas donde
quieren que los republicanos tengan los
recortes